good morning with john langler heather
mills at the anchor desk bianca holman
watching traffic nathan tannenbaum and
if you haven't already heard the wind at
your house here's what's happening this
is our camera down at sunset station the
wind is whipping now there is a wind
advisory that does not include las vegas
but a lot of times when we have a whole
bunch of wind blowing in it actually
warms the temperature up before it
starts dropping we're up to 79 degrees
but look at this winds gusting close to
45 miles an hour steadily over 20 miles
an hour so the wind advisory for western
clark county does not include las vegas
but does include indian springs a lot of
lincoln county a lot of night county
parts of esmeralda parts of southern
california also they've had some
stronger rain up around the st george
area so these rain showers are really
not the big story there will be some
showers and they are moving through very
quickly so here's what we're talking
about this is what we call round one of
clouds wind and rain round two is going
to be coming up next week we want to get
you through the next several hours
though i think it actually may drop 10
degrees by the time we get to 8 then
start turning things back around
scattered storms should roll out of here
after noon and 72 then just very windy
for 3 p.m at 76 that's going to be the
high today
74 at 6 p.m and again very windy for
whatever your outdoor plans are